10-11 if all starches what is this guy
offering me an ailing on everything this
is worrying he wants to go all the way
tonight you go a great look at least two
cool guys hanging out with they're
traumatized girlfriends and this guy
just sitting there staring at his dick
and this guy just sitting over there
wishing he could be drinking more
mountain dew nothing's real oh [ __ ] more
gamertags I gotta oh no I keep cussing
yeah TC do you see that was right in my
ear no so you can screaming the whole
video this time I'm upset for some
reason okay alright so here we see the
veteran with a roommate for the
remainder of the video we're just gonna
we're gonna try and talk in our regular
voices but that doesn't make it closer
to the way okay everyone scooch in on
this microphone get ready all right all
right hold on let me here we see the
yummy wakame pull up my commentary voice
for you okay you see Christopher Walken
Christopher what the cruise on Hawkins I
lay here and see this weather little bit
light let me get my kind of darkness as
you stared into the abyss sorry I forget
we're recording right now so did I I
love your wall put your arms around me
fiddly digits itchy britches I love your
wall wash room smells it could be
cleaner stench of cigarettes and stale
urea love you all oh no I just realized
this whole time I was going the exact
opposite of the way I was supposed to be
going so it's like if I was playing oh
no the pipe is broken and I'm dying good
league ball save me look what's the kick
button put your mind to gather more
hi turi hahaha what we have skill points
dude what this game has leveled look
roosting this game is basically my soul
diving it's like Skyrim but not fun and
even Skyrim isn't very fun alright Sarah
were together stubborn I the guys you
know what if there's a if anyone in the
comments of this video gets mad that'll
mean something someone watched it so
that'll never happen I'm shaking
everybody did the freedom to become a
true black guy
I was waiting for that comment oh no I'm
good oh the racism well now you should
jump and play basketball and eat fried
chicken and wear your underwear outside
of your pants okay you're basically
Batman or Superman oh I know it doesn't
do that anymore oh yeah Superman for
some reason got rid of his underwear or
at least started wearing it right gotta
go fact I to Superman have little man
fingerless gloves now that looked like
no it looks like really long sleeves on
like a better you'd ring a sweater
that's kind of eggs or just kind of put
peek out a little bit Superman looks
like a little kid again now because of
his costume redesign he also looks like
a hard-partying according to and Jackson
hi Jackson loves Superman in more ways
than one confirmed hahaha
huh I don't know I'm just gonna die haha
good is it accurate what's the button to
scream for medic II Jeff TC are you even
participating anymore you know you can't
hold it back anymore no Jackson little
touch you run together oh oh so this is
just gonna be getting knocked on your
ass montage 2015 there will be a counter
in the top of the screen for how many
times you get knocked on your ass uh you
can run through the water watch you like
go 10 feet go into like the five foot
section of like the pool nor that part
in halo 1 and then it just like Call of
Duty physics where you can't stand five
feet above the water and you die yeah
remember that part or in Halo one in
like the island section where you could
just walk out of the level and just like
just like leave the island and there's
no there's no fly kill boundary in the
water and it's not like you can't fall
to death so you can just walk under
water for like 300 miles and all the way
so so basically Master Chief canva can
become the zombies from the dawn of the
dead on the dead remake hey Jackson this
is a real pipe dream
is that an ascetic truck
you got God go save that guy from those
those car robbers they're clearly what
they're all white what a black guy
stopping robbery what is this opposite
world haha so much video why this much
racism I'm half black okay and I'm Asian
then we got TC to be funny last name is
Mendoza I'm every ethnicity except maybe
like Middle Eastern German i am german
no I'm German no I'm pinhead Larry I'm
clearly more German I kid oh yeah
supplies I can find let's get our little
kiosk maybe you'll find a violent left 4
dead island it's left 4 dead 3 you know
it'd be the biggest middle fingers and
the developers of this if left 4 dead 3
took place on unlike uh no resort island
just so they could say we can do this
game way better yeah he would hey you
know you know pokemon and you know dead
island right I don't know anything about
pokemons other than that my sister likes
it well if i crash-landed on an island
retreat i was inhabited with pokemon i
would find the one i could find the
biggest flying one I would and then ride
him back to civilization and use his
awesome powers to take over society to
go can I just like riding you two around
like like no cuz like a holden holden
saw on my back man who is his own person
he'd like created himself he's basically
the god of pokemon who technically is
well actually actually scratch that
because there are stronger pokemon than
later no new one is God PO commands well
yeah we do too is jesus PO commands cuz
he's like his nicer son we just think we
need to like sacrifices himself for our
sins no that's me you I can't tell i
don't know he likes fossil think wow is
that even what the [ __ ] is all what is
that helix fossil a huge he likes
bossing you time why is misty so hot
she's like tenure too dammit japan
and why do you have a front you have a
problem exam period pedophile know that
that show was on like five years before
I was even born that character if that
character was real she would be like 30
right now wouldn't be that weird but
they keep making more seasons and she
never ages so it's made me out age the
character and the show and become weird
what that Ash and Pikachu have never
aged a single day well I mean Pikachu's
gonna hit puberty any game no because
suddenly he's just gonna be like his
voice is way deeper as she still gonna
be like bless you bless you sir for
pokemon reference anyway where are we
saying no this is this is 2015 Jackson I
don't even know a year it is it's all
how do you kick in this game there's a
way to kick that I forgot I don't know
what fun two frets Jackson you're
getting Bened you push the boy did I did
it okay did I hear it let me put lemon
oh I try I wanna learn how to kick what
do you do take this zombie ah this Gator
boys party it's like those walking dead
characters
no I stopped caring about the show after
Bob died oh you gotta see the new is so
bright I don't care is bobbing it no I
don't care and then Shane in it you
always hated his Shane's ghost in it
he's so hateable he's like hahaha Shane
is like the Antichrist you know I used
to know a guy named Shane yeah it was
actually quite nice yeah at one point
I'm he gotta go ha you know like those
like yeah those leader those leaders of
Gatorade ha ha ha ha yeah ha ha it's
hammer time ever hold on he's just done
oh no TC yeah leaders of gatoring oh
like you're in my second grade he
brought one of those to lunch and just
like jug the whole thing without even
breathing this is great right this is my
friend Shane by the way oh god it's a
monster closet it's like we're playing
doom 3 guys why aren't we playing doom 3
right now because of reasons oh my god